I have thrived on one simple idea which
is placing achievable goals in front of
you you know that I never would give
myself a goal like writing a novel I
find goals like that really intimidating
I do well by saying I'm going to try and
write every day for 10 days this is one
you know I remember when I was first
starting to teach myself to write so I
would say I'm gonna go away for 10 days
I'll go on a 10-day retreat and I'll
write every day for 10 days with the
goal of one short story let's see if we
can just just I'm gonna come back with
one short story I can handle my friends
and usually those simple actions give
you confidence you know I did that I
wrote a short story and I gave it to my
friends and they really liked it I mean
they're my friends right and they were
encouraging and I knew that there were a
couple paragraphs that were really good
you know when you start accessing that
part of yourself and you give yourself
you know achievable goals I remember I
didn't decide that I wanted to direct
films I told myself that I was gonna
direct a short film and it's gonna make
it super manageable something that I
could afford to produce I didn't need to
ask anybody I took the money I made from
Dead Poets Society and I made a short
film you know I've got a graphic novel
coming out that's kind of weird you know
for an actor to do and I made a
documentary last year I wrote a
children's book last year I've acted in
plays to a lot of people that strikes
them as weird you know that I or they
can accuse me of being a dilettante or
something like that right but I believe
in cultivating the attitude of a student
at all times and putting yourself out of
your comfort zone you know if all I did
was act since I was 13 I could do that
but it doesn't help me become a better
actor writing helps
become a better actor directing you know
I I'm trying to direct a movie right now
I'm trying to talk other actors hit to
being in the movie and they you know
they say no all the time the Basterds
and and but it helps me understand
wow that's how she works I would have
never thought that about the script you
know what she's right it is strange why
does that do that now when I'm meeting
at directors trying to talk me into
doing a movie I know how sensitive
they're feeling you know and I know how
to talk to them in a way that's not
going to be hurtful or disrespectful I
have had a lot of experience at
different things and you know give
myself a goal of a first draft of
something with plenty of time you know
but you but you have to make it if you
give you something evil the great things
you don't want to position yourself to
fail you know because failing is
depressing and it makes you lose steam
and whereas if you say like I don't have
to direct a movie by next year or
anything like that but I will have a
first draft or I'll die I'm going to
have this first draft and so what do I
really need to do that well I need to
have a outline by next week and then
I'll make that outline into a 10 page
treatment I'll turn that 10 page
treatment into a twenty page treatment
then I'll try to write a first draft the
screenplay with my goal of it being 60
pages you know in and like that and okay
and invariably often you can get done
sooner than that